le festival open campus a lieu du 6 au
10 novembre 2017 avec l'objectif de
proposer aux usagers de venir tester
fabriquer river le campus pendant une
semaine donc on a fait cinq thématiques
sur la culture d'abord lundi en faisant
revenir le bus le proto bus sur le
campus et parler de librairies et des
mystères de l'univers avec hervé dole
pour une popup livre éric est aussi le
soir faire un cinéma mobile avec
stéphanie wheel avec des projections de
films dont certains partiront aux
sélections pour les oscars
le mardi on a voulu se concentrer sur
les pratiques collaboratives et mise en
place par des chercheurs qui essaye
d'accompagner d'autres chercheurs sur
des enjeux numériques que sont le big
data
le cloud computing et la fabrication
numérique tout ça pour les aider à faire
ou développer leurs recherches mercredi
d'une progression peut être plus
habitant faire faire ce lien là en tout
cas sur la thématique de l'éducation et
comment apprendre dans un écosystème
libre et plusieurs projets le learning
center de paris saclay évidemment tant
que bâtiment qui repensé la biotech y
repenser l'accès à la connaissance à
travers
des programmations particulière mais
aussi des associations et des programmes
individuels
je pense notamment à l'école
démocratique de marie gervais qui a
projet de monter une école avait tout et
un nouveau maire de repenser l éducation
en mettant l'élève le plus possible en
situation de liberté plus j'ai dit avoir
été un vrai un peu professionnelle si on
peut dire on a voulu se poser la
question à nous mêmes c'est quoi les
tirs l'au-delà campus à quoi ça sert
et qu'est ce qu'on pense à plusieurs
enfin aujourd'hui c'est ce que vous
voyez derrière c'est alexis notre fab
lab manager qui fait une formation à la
réalité virtuelle pour que justement les
jeunes habitants mais aussi des
étudiants viennent apprendre à faire
leur propre environnement de réalité
virtuelle par eux mêmes cette année
c'était la première édition du festival
et on a bien sûr envie de recommencer le
retour qu'on en a ce sentiment d'être un
peu en famille ils avoir pu montrer des
porteurs de communauté qui agissent que
les jours sur le campus et notamment ici
au proto et mettre en avant comment
est-ce qu'un lieu peut aider des gens
qui agissent sur le territoire et donner
envie à d'autres de continuer à
s'impliquer sur les projets qui est ici